[Music]
[Applause]
girl waiting for celebrity over there
but anyway I said in front of a
man-child
kept poking at my screen the whole time
now arrest you by your life no I was I'm
not even Tudor I'm like can you please
stop and then he was like what am i
doing anything like oh my god dude so
many of you guys who sympathizes me
right now but anyway we left LAX they
told us there was no more room in the
overhead
we checked both of our carry-on and they
said that it was arrived here in
sunlight we get here and only one
[Applause]
so we're waiting and we're waiting and
we're waiting and the lights never
arrived so we thought of setting a claim
it turns out that if they get to be
George but for some reason they suffer a
bit our luggage and one of them just
stayed in New York and that's the
luggage that has all of our clothes and
so now we're just we could all we have
is our toiletries we don't have any
[Applause]
start to the trip hobbies
positive pretty amazing opportunity that
we got so the Tourism Board of Puerto
Rico and we're just so excited to check
out what prairie glass offer this is
amazing thank you babe honestly thank
you guys for all the support over the
years
would have never done these
opportunities now the drivers calling me
so we gotta go these are the fangirls I
was talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
beach front view
no way oh that's tight
[Applause]
[Music]
we just don't have clothes my teeth
right quick even though we're gonna go
eat because I have that morning brush
[Music]
what do you think this song was you're
hoping a Collider you want to try a
virgin piña colada from Puerto Rico yeah
a virgin one yeah oh do you know what
that means it's when they make the drink
without alcohol they put everything else
in there except for the alcohol yeah cos
pina coladas are from Puerto Rico Parra
check out your virgin pina colada
I got a regular chickaletta Cheers
lemonade we're having our first meal
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my view this lunch waters better
than lunch lunch lemons are starting to
get droopy I need sleep gives me life
food I got this skirt steak with
plantains and then Isaac you decided to
get a lien food
[Music]
I know if I dig it up I'm never gonna
wake up it's a very bumpy ride
my gosh I'm blinking see how tired I am
I'd literally just said it like
something that about me oh that's pretty
you missed it keep missing the virile
struggles of a vlogger
[Music]
so they could be long that I cannot
sleep especially in public for some
reason without having my mouth wide open
you doesn't have to sleep with him as
long as I ever lay in fence my mouth
early morning hi good morning sweetie
we're here we were 3/4 she woke up the
funniest way and I rolled the camera a
little too weak
[Music]
you still remember how to ride a horse
from Hawaii
no you're nervous about riding the horse
been ten that's four years old that's
four years ago
when you were six guns in your channel
[Music]
love birds migrating you're just
watching recently we're watching though
something like the movie or something
and they were over to West world and so
they're really galloping on the horse
never again you're gonna do today I
really want to but I know we can't on
these kind of horseback riding trip
anyway so like West well they were like
super galloping you're just going really
really fast a really fun when we last
did this horseback riding thing and
which was the no way and they let us
gallop for like about twenty feet or
something and that was so like the
funnest like two seconds of my life
and so I wish we could just do that in
the wild by myself with my own horse
just gaussians the wind but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Sebastian's his name he said I'm gonna
name him Sebastian and the main
character's name is a true Texan born
what's your horse's name like it already
knows where to go what's your name
Paco to me so so shaky sorry in advance
was really a really shaky horse footage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my leg so Kate these horses total like
really like old-time and I use just like
guys because they both want to be the
first ones in the group so you're way
over there and then me and Paco we're
like
that's so doable
nope
[Applause]
it's pretty crazy so the entire time we
were out there not a single speck okay
may look a little bit arena like
sprinkling a little bit but the moment
we come inside it's pouring you keep
getting the b-roll of that
[Applause]
boring like crazy with our timing was
impeccable like you literally just
missed all that
nice and dry all right mommy how did you
like the horseback riding it was
love-love members offering any titles of
the horse to do something like go
forward or not you're listening to me
and I felt like we were you can
meditating like an avatar like Wendy and
Chloe both connected to Paco I wish my
it won't turn play wait yeah your horse
kept going in front of everyone and it's
like it wanted to be first yeah I mean
what's a horse now yeah
[Applause]
Yeah right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the Isaac spell
[Music]